obligados a huir de sus hogares las
familias se aglutinan en una escuela en
desuso en la ciudad de hasta daba en la
provincia de kunar en el este del país
son sólo algunas de las miles de
personas desplazadas
luego tampoco global de los talibanes
llegaron empezaron a luchar en nuestro
pueblo mis animales desaparecieron hubo
disparos una de mis hijas de siete años
salió durante los combates y desapareció
no sé si está vivo o muerto
desde el viernes cuatro capitales de
provincias han caído en manos de los
insurgentes
las últimas conquistas de los talibanes
con surf una gran ciudad norteña sarepul
previamente se tomaron sever jan house
sand y naranja la capital de la
provincia ni bros un funcionario local
de nin ros culpó a kabul
libros y libros estaba amenazada por
todas partes pedimos ayuda porque no
había suficiente apoyo militar hace años
que no hay suficiente policía ejército y
patrullas de frontera
saladillo señor camps gran parte del
campo ha caído en manos del grupo
islamista desde mayo cuando las tropas
extranjeras se marcharon washington
sostiene que la retirada de sus fuerzas
fue la decisión correcta después de 20
años de conflicto la retirada de eeuu se
completará justo antes del aniversario
número 20 de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre